food production doesn't get more
fundamental than this
but if a worker on this norfolk farm
gets pinged they won't be bringing in
any more harvest
for 10 days high summer has brought no
respite
from the nhs test and trace app
farm workers just one of the categories
not included
in the government exemption for the food
industry
we've got a crop of peas in the field
behind me now the peas don't know
whether it's the 16th of august or
whether it's the 22nd of july
and so you know it's to them when
they're ready to be harvested we've got
to be able to harvest them
and unfortunately we've got businesses
now that are under real pressure because
people are having to self-isolate when
they haven't got the virus
food is on the move here
a giant distribution center where test
and release will soon replace
self-isolation
an exemption that will cover around 10
000 workers in food production
and transportation the lorries may be on
the move
here but with supermarket retail staff
and some manufacturers not included this
exemption
may just push problems elsewhere in the
supply chain and business groups
are warning it is inevitable other
sectors will have to be included
before the self-isolation rules are
lifted altogether on august the 16th
there will also be limited exemptions
for workers in 15 other critical sectors
including energy and civil nuclear power
digital infrastructure
water chemicals medicines and medical
supplies
and defense government will notify
employers that are eligible
only named workers can apply and they'll
have to be double vaccinated
with isolation due to lift for those
who've had two jabs in three weeks time
many argue there's no need to wait
government scientists are adamant that
it's the virus not the app
that's out of control the pandemic is
because we have a pandemic
and this is the first time really that
we have been on an upward curve an
upward trajectory
so it is inevitable that a large number
of people
will be being asked to isolate this is
the way that we can
stop transmission occurring through the
country so this is not um
an inconvenience it is actually an
essential
intervention for all of us
[Music]
london underground is the latest service
to be hit with 300 staff isolating
one line will be closed all weekend the
mismatch between the app
and actual behavior continues to have
consequences
paul kelso sky news